he's one of our favorite guests and I
would say that with him not even sitting
here to my right you can follow on both
Twitter and Instagram at Frank Caliendo
and find out where you can watch his
comic stylings if you will at Aaron
Caliendo dot-com he is none other than
Frank Caliendo how are you Frank
doing well yeah I deserve a little more
than that but that's all right
take it bring it down focus don't don't
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to
have the the crowd and joy well it's
it's the rare bring it down focus that
you hear me focus on laughter and
applause I like silence it's odd yeah
well here's the thing this air I live in
Arizona and in this era when you have to
chew to breathe it's a problem it's a
struggle it's not that bad though what
for you yeah you have a little bit of it
on so I brought my you were keying in on
my props I know so I brought you're
already wearing your Chiefs yeah cuz I
don't want to change okay has some
Chiefs fans over there but the funny
thing is that only takes so much to make
this transformation so now I'm putting
some glasses on and then who doesn't
travel with their own fake mustache I
mean a lot of people whoever doesn't
travel with their own fake mustache to
cast the first stone
there it is there we go oh yeah and now
I bet a lot of you didn't know this but
Andy Reid does a lot of impressions
the first sweating it's not sticking
because you have too much sweat oh dear
I didn't plan for that all right who
would you like would you like a fighter
that what do you got for me on Andy Reid
pretty my Andy Reid is at the time is
yours that's all I got and him working
on my home's like I every time I try to
do Patrick my home's it turns into
either Fozzie Bear yeah or Charles
Barkley and that's the weird thing
because those comment
in between right here and right here and
then you get Patrick Mahal's that I
could have been they somewhere in there
and I'd screw that the moustache is not
what John Madden think of and you look
at all the things you could do and you
have a plan to do some props and then
they don't stick to and then boom your
segments are a lot worse than what you
had planned but rich is used to that a
lot of people do things that he doesn't
really care for all right
so what I really appreciate is that
you're always on Instagram and stuff
like that yeah
my daughter has started doing Jon Gruden
which is amazing and now it's
interesting because you're having
trouble talking to me like this because
I do the Jon Gruden and everybody knows
to do the Jon Gruden so they're kind of
bored with it yeah so and I'm really
bored with it it's nice but my daughter
starts doing Jon Gruden I do John Green
it'll get like 5,000 views or something
like that she does Jon Gruden it gets
like 20,000 views like I made it so my
daughter has to be in all my videos over
it's over it's all right if I put it
somewhere else I don't know it's stuck
on your cheek all right so then you know
it really stinks when you have a plan so
well holder is it you don't travel with
a backup fake mustache oh no whose dude
who travels are the back of mustache
rats maybe that's one of the stupidest
things I've ever heard in my entire life
traveling with a fake backup mustache
well now you're a backup fake mustache
now here's an al you know that it's
difficult to pull off the Andy Reid fake
mustache bit in this type of what a
Robert Downey jr. Andy Reid
you had no idea we're gonna be doing
this nice job Segway
do me a favor
enjoy me people clap look at this guy
he's doing his own this guy's doing his
own television show
where's the shades that nobody knows who
he is good job all right get him a
mustache so he can go out of here safely
about a new a new product Robert Downey
jr. mints no I just made it up right
here it's gonna be pretty brilliant we
uh 1 million they don't taste the same
but each one right just as good as last
so how would Pacino coach the game as
Andy Reid how would that work you gotta
fight for your right to party no that's
the wrong thing isn't it
no I what I would do okay try where the
most completely like no you've got to be
that was real your hands are on your
hips like what is happening and why
isn't rich going to commercial it's okay
it's okay this is part of it let's talk
to Super Bowl de I yes really I I don't
and I think I've heard you talk about
this a little bit but we know what
happens when I think you've talked about
something yes why is it that I really
want Andy Reid to win this thing
everybody love who doesn't like it is
that it is he must be that good of a
person because you don't see like
everybody talks about everybody has some
naysayers right he seems to have just
everybody like I mean I don't know I'm
I've never met here's what it is - Frank
Frank Caliendo here in the rich geyser
here's what it is yes he's been around
for a while yes he's been around for a
while and hasn't won one and so we
already have a soft spot yes he is a guy
that had gotten the love of so many
different people but he also looks like
this cartoon character that's a lovable
he does he looks like it wants a
cheeseburger it's easy and he does it
and he wears that on his sleeve doesn't
really yes he does I like and he heats
so he he's just looks like a guy that
you want to root for he does have a
Wilford Brimley sort of diabeetus type
of look that he's got going on it's true
I'm sure you would love he's a guest
this week not anymore
it's the right thing to do I've heard
Berman talk about this it sounds like a
setup and rittany you know Annie Reed
what am i it [ __ ] yeah yeah I could
give them up right now it's just that
what his offensive coordinator is the
best Berman name of all time
Erik sleeping with the enemy so is it
great that is an actual grads a great
one another another great Berman ISM
from back in the day was remember the
pitcher Jim Deshaies no Bert's well Todd
which hand do I throw worth yeah we
can't do a froward yeah you know a lot
of people yeah back back that was
actually that honk came from inside and
I don't know the lights are brighter
than normal it's and it's a 2 o'clock
Eastern time zone that is who where it's
just the lights plus the humidity leads
to no prop comedy but yeah and in the
same way Andy Reid adores Iran everyone
like my kid my eight-year-old said
watching the national championship game
I loved him when he showed up on the
screen I love him dad yeah my daughter
might not my daughter thought he was
great my wife watched him when he came
on screen and said that's not real
[Applause]
that's somebody doing a character
no that's Cookie Monster and every time
I tried to do it as a he does say has
that prep I'm throwing out the proof
coffee phone another Prescott and it's
always said like c is for cookie it's
good you're just waiting for somebody to
dump truck a bunch of cookies in there
and he's gonna teach you today we're
gonna learn about the little C that's
like what the heck is going on no no I
told you we needed this place
soundproofed I do prop comedy and
audio-visual material by the way that
was very sound that sounded like shefter
a little bit less after would you go
higher register question resources my
wish tool that's Adam Chevy I I was told
that there would be absolutely no
heavy-duty truck movement this J blazer
comes in listen I know I don't you hurt
I didn't say it set another do with me
but they're loud people a
mother struts I hear about the demi
lovato think about that punch my tooth
out listen I was working out late a lot
of me people fell inside if you don't
know who that is
look it up google it right now in your
phone there's a lot more human segments
so let me just say this
so watch pregame watch pregame it's
gonna be incredible pregame I'm gonna
lift weights i sat next to him on the
flight out here five hours did you
really see clothes how much about him
did you hear he got me kicked out of the
first Super Bowl I ever went to what
yeah come on so it was in Jacksonville
was it Fox at the time Eagles patron oh
yeah see this is gonna be amazing
you gotta come down to the sidelines and
watch the planes go over the national
anthem it's the most amazing thing I've
ever seen your entire life I'm like okay
you have a child yet no it's gonna be
better than that it's gonna be proud
so I go down there the national anthem
the planes fly over is like what was
that like I'm like it was incredible
somebody comes over from the NFL they're
like where's your credential I hold up
my credential which has a green marking
on it yeah which the people that Fox
told me you can go on the field of you
can kick the ball
[Laughter]
so they're like you can kick the ball
I'm like I hold off on that they goes no
what are you doing down here I go really
I'm just here to watch this because my
friend Jay which I used the term friend
lightly now yeah but I was like my
friend Jay said come down here and watch
this he's like okay you gotta go I was
like okay and I questioned I not like a
jerk I just question like hatin but
doesn't this past mean he goes just go I
go doesn't this past mean he goes that's
it
Rip's the credential off me kicked me
out of the Super Bowl and I was kicked
out of Jacksonville the entire stadium
just out on the street cry just crying
and before I had done the impression of
all the guys by the pregame show yeah
Fox had the Fox had it so I was like
what do I do
I finally sneak my way back in because
the security guards were hitting on some
girl so I waited for that you know we're
guarding the stadium meanwhile I'm
sneaking through tippy-toes you gotta
like shaggy Scoob like let's make a
break for it and then we ran our feet
traveled circles for a little sweat and
there was no dog with me but I thought
there was so
I get in there they're laughing at the
good parts now so I get in there and I
say that the president of Fox Sports
David Hill I'm like listen I don't know
what transpired over how this happened
but you guys know me hmm I'm not a
troublemaker
yeah I'm not a problem you know I I play
by the rules yes it's incredible
humidity and they said David Hill is
Australia like that where are you bad
I'll take care of it so I get back in
they get me my credential back oh and I
but the rest of the Super Bowl I
couldn't enjoy you know I'm sweating
them like sad I miss I missed most half
the first half of the Super Bowl and
Terry's like what's going on over there
you got a problem I got kicked out in
the Super Bowl my plan worked
come on don't make fun of me it was one
of those just surreal moments like I and
there was actually another comedian
who's Craig shoemaker who had video of
it he was just video and cuz he saw me
being walked out and so it still exists
today I think it's a shoemaker probably
has it I didn't ever want to see it
again I was like what is your credential
for Super Bowl fifty four I'm going I'm
gonna be back home so you're no longer
allowed to be at the Super Bowl this day
yeah I'm not allowed back in ever again
I'm allowed to come during the week and
talk about the Super Bowl but I'm never
allowed to be near the Super Bowl Brian
Calley I know here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so do you want to predict the
game as yourself do you want to predict
them Robert Downey jr. your vision how
America shield gets broken but that's
okay I know they knew that I would like
to hear how the Chiefs win this game as
by presented by Morgan Freeman ah yes we
look at the tremendous defense and
offense of the San Francisco 49ers but
in the end the style our Power Star one
one syllable star power of Patrick
mahomes and the Chiefs purveyor
that's all I got so yeah bring it down
focus here we go get bring it down focus
everybody let's do let's do seven a
smith predicting the 49ers I have to say
that I look in my my inside without
prevarication I understand unequivocally
that this who do we say was gonna order
the San Francisco 49ers are gonna take
down the Kansas City Chiefs in a
masterpiece with a lot of syllables what
yeah so who uses the more syllable
Stephen a or Jim Rome no I'm gonna hook
raise that bring it around you've just
brought on the jukebox Caliendo that's
the calendar jukebox Caliendo jukebox he
just pressed a seven for Jim Rome
incredible phenomenal arugula dear the
Tony Romo working on nobody wrote in
here there oh no I did hear that please
yeah oh here we go
this incredible and amazing and
amazingly incredibly amazing I can't
believe this play what's gonna happen
here I just imagine him buying a pizza
or something
Jim this is oh look what's gonna happen
here that Oh what happened you take a
look at that box and you see the stains
that's not pepperoni what's gonna happen
here Jim they screwed it up got us a
sausage double cheese open the box
hello friends this is wrong got to be
here for radio that's a very good Romo
cuz cuz there's there's there's there's
the effusive Romo where he he gets a
little bit higher res you've got word
you know like he's excited be excited
Romo we're here we go
there's also the understanding it's
really really good this guy split wide
they all blend together Jim really
really thought it was sexy cuz he's like
Patrick remote-sensing
look at this playing I just love
everything he's doing I want to kiss him
and hug him and make him my best friend
babe I like weighted Tony Romo's like he
didn't it's coming from my account
I'm an impresario and you did the one
ring they're gonna score 600 points in
the second half here right Jim this is
gonna they're gonna be like six seven
hundred points in the second half and
people responding like I don't remember
Romo saying that yeah you can get people
to believe anything like this segment
was great by me it very well was you
know how much I laugh at me coming
coming on my face hurts every time you
come on here at Frank Kelly I know on
both Twitter and Instagram Frank
Caliendo calm on April 4th Aurora
Illinois at the Paramount Theater
beautiful Lake Tahoe Nevada on April
11th at the mount blue yeah
Resort Casino and Spa men in May and
August you'll be in was Washington and
Detroit Michigan and so many other
places in between Frank Caliendo calm
and Cali under cast Kelly under cast as
well Allan Frank try to be serious
there's that as well we're dead been
down for a little bit but Caliendo cast
Callie and yet the Frank Caliendo cast
podcast yeah alongside John home
birdsong Scott long and others you get
that right yes got long he pronounced
that really what I do Jon Hoeber Jon
Hoeber another he he does amazing
impressions as well okay so they just go
back will go back and forth just doing
Shannon Sharpe talking joke it's cute
it's cute yeah yeah yeah yeah ever do
that for you know the Shannon Sharpe and
Mel Kiper jr. in the same room confused
who they're with me play what man
this segment got even worse
[Laughter]
we'll take your calls and tell you who's
on tomorrow's great show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app